you don't say we zijn possède et
aujourd'hui on se trouve sur la démo de
grève
degroof et j'ai absolument aucune idée
de ce qu'on fout au milieu d'un désert
mais qu'est ce qu'est venu faire ici le
becks qu'il est né ici où est maman
maman maman je n'en sais absolument rien
en tout cas c'est un jeu qui s'annonce
bien sympathique bananes ananas top
c'est à dire que entre le jour et la
nuit il ya une bonne différence à savoir
que normalement la nuit d'après ce que
j'ai vu sur le jeu on se fera attaquer
par des mots ans voilà notre seule arme
sera de la lumière une lampe torche une
flamme tout ça alors y accourent cette
maison là j'aimerais j'aimerais savoir
les sortes de bruits ne brille pas très
rassurant
or qui sait que ça pourquoi cette boîte
d'allumettes retourne très intimidant ok
d'accord donc gêner le maître pour que
j'utilise une allumette en plein jour
quelle utilité y en a aucune fait pour
brouiller la télé pas du tout a suffi ça
veut dire qu'il ya une sorte de gros
fantôme alors je compose de lancer
d'allumettes au pif voilà on a tué le
poteau comme ça on est bien aux
premières loges d'une série fantastique
au bas des trésors stage et j'ai peur
alors qu'il fait jour alors watts
on est bien d'accord n'y avait pas ça
juste avant mais non c'est quoi ce
bordel c'est les a lus mais qu'est ce
qui se passe qu'est ce qui se passe
assez bon ses revenus en mode normal tu
as essayé mais c'était carrément
ensorcelé il ya un gros problème
je suis en train de délirer georges a
besoin que c'est moi qui paie si côté
quai vu des bâtiments ou encore valence
était bien dans le jeu à moins que moi
que c'est à lui même de merde [ __ ] je
veux m'en débarrasser je peux même pas
comme ça qu'on se prend un gros train de
face qu'est ce que c'est que ça activate
assayas et des lumières d'accord donc ça
à quelqu'un d'être désactivé on va se
retrouver dans le noir complet ça c'est
sûr et certain avec des sortes de mecs
un peu déformé qui vont nous attaquer
j'ai plutôt peur où ils veulent en venir
là j'en ai marre mois au voilà j'avais
dit quoi
aa elle moi je n'allume est te maudira
numéros de cirque ça aussi quoi aller
c'est patrick legrand au tour après le
saut d'obstacles le lancer le met un
morceau de sudoku falla non par la non
par la voilà un peu de lumière du jour
c'est le seul endroit de la grotte où tu
peut bronzer quoi en plus il ya de l'eau
et tout pour tuer des ratés [ __ ] c'est
parfait ici on reste là allez les
vacances voilà qu'au bout de cette
grotte j'aimerais bien savoir là c'est
la fête des hobbits ici comment ça se
passe droite ou gauche
alors qu'est-ce qu'on a par là où il ya
un truc là qu est ce que c est ce que a
c'est quoi ça dans lé faut jeter des
allumettes dans le trou c'est le
traitement patrick pour son numéro de
cirque et il met la pression ce jeu quoi
en oui enfin brûlé un truc vous [ __ ]
le feu à la grange le gros pierrot
[ __ ] mais la nouvelle est tombée comme
ça quoi obama a laissé nuit mais non
mais [ __ ] mais non j'étais sûr j'étais
sûr je m'en fous j'attends ici tu as lu
au moins l'ensemble dégage ça marche
oh oh oh lui un bruit y avait un cri
c'est quoi c'est toi attendons
finalement tu veux bien manger avec moi
relaie mon bois au bordel de merde non
mais là je descends plus ces filles là
bas ok donc c'est en fait c'est une
sorte de sauvegarde tager déflation les
poils qui se hérissent quoi oh oui de
flash lite ça c'est bien ça va être
moins galère que de mettre de l'essence
d'appui ensuite de faire marche pas la
vache c'est bon tu brûles c'est bon ça
n'a aucun sens que c'est que ça du
cassoulet non non si les pâtes riz au
oui au mémo futin de bordel je suis
bloqué mais non arrête de te traîner
pour le cirque patrick ça suffit j'en ai
marre on peut monter ici on peut
peut-être l'allumer non non j'ai cru que
c'était une match que je la lui qui va
au bout d'un feu d'artifice la ola
google et tout ce qui fait son ensemble
mais là-bas il ya un autre truc je
veille dans cette maison là bas au
[ __ ] mais revient en tout cas mon
chien mon frère mon père meurt
mais mais [ __ ] mais brouillard lève
ses gros yeux
s'il vous plaît oui là pour l'algérie
nul à chier mais on a rarement vu des
gens aussi nul que moi quoi du coup j'ai
plus rien peut faire un feu de camp un
kite des allumettes quoi la faute quand
ça y est c'est nul oui cet homme il
saute cas à 2
regardez ils sont même pas juste là il
est il temps ses jambes c'est tout ça
c'est plus la nuit l'orgasme casseroles
carrément pas un pet de lumière rouge
est je pense un feu quelque part
bon allez on va tenter d'aller un point
alors je suis à un point b tout là bas
c'est parti c'est quoi ça meurt mais je
lamoureux auquel était dégueulasse il
était un simple d'une sorte d' enfant
difforme en plus de ça quand tu perds ta
gueule brûle ménard député mais c'est
quoi il commençait à brûler puis l'a
fait non je ne vole plus désormais tu
meurs tiens je suis nue mais il ment
goisses je sais pas pourquoi c'est
horrible et vous savez comme moi dont je
me touche le front c'est cadré problème
brûle mais regardez-moi ça soit c'est un
feu d'artifice quand je les classe balle
ait jeté appétit est partout et moi je
veux pas un peu d'artistes et je veux
que tu mon gars fire voilà altintop a
touché à tanger en temps ils crient
kenavo dota il cause sa bouche à oreille
pour crier quoi ça suffit
talabani avait des têtes la lumière je
veux aller l'éolien de la lumière comme
il y en a combien là ça suffit
[ __ ] ils sont par milliers c'est une
colonie de vacances en fait de gens chez
nous ici et là bas il ya un truc qui un
truc à la lumière moi je vais aller là
c'est ouvrir un salon de thé avec john
comme pouvoir m'aider et tous ont
l'habitude
alors ça se trouve c'est l'endroit où et
toute la colonie sérieux ah oui et
sortes de champignons lumineux là qui va
nous sauver
oui yes c'est une lampe de poche copie
au [ __ ] regarder la télé elle est de
retour
on a tout ce qu'il faut [ __ ] c'est le
paradis allez on se pose on va être la
télé ouais attendait mais pas été
impactés sur sa très bonne endroit je
donnerais 5 étoiles sur le site voyages
avec talent de poche points comme il est
8h45 et bienvenue dans l'endroit des
gens celle où la température est
d'environ 43 degrés si vous manquez des
biens des lampes sont à votre
disposition par terre dans la mini fort
et c'est pourquoi c'est le petit jingle
de de jean leloup radio on va essayer de
résister dans une bo de bagnards nul
c'est quoi c'est un bazooka c'est quoi
mais sa tête d'un bidon d'essence
quand donc cet homme est carrément show
with their way
wen est une sorte de feu de ouf non
l'allumette à les brûler yes
alors tu rentres what what what
désormais et la mecque quoi des boîtes
de l'armée c'est scandaleux
mes cheveux impeccables photo à la
mecque qui lui ont fait une danse des
braises sur le feu comme ça non mais ça
suffit
voila voila connaît depuis tout juste
active et saab et en tulle ampoules idée
de génie attentats les sur le toit mais
non mais et quand je saute regarder quoi
il serait juste sur la pointe des pieds
voilà tu marches sur la pointe des pieds
à tangente encaisse coucher j'active
hockey d'actifs et de lumières partout
mon gars et je protège le générateur
moyens dans la lumière
émond a fait moins le malin quand ça
part en fumée comme ça
elle est où la forêt john la forêt
maléfique ou jabbar au plus tard pour
les générateurs c'est un an plus tard
obtient on attend on attend on attend
vient de battre viens te battre
[ __ ] j'ai eu peur du nombre c'est toi
télé qui m'appelle je suis désolé bah
oui mais oui mais je peux pas prendre
soin de toi papa s'occupe des méchants
méchants des mondiaux c'est l'homme
célèbre enceinte télé protège toi tu es
les protège droits télés protège moi tv
télévision télé celle d'un sous l'égide
de l'ue pour tous parce que je t'ai fait
chuter deux fois trahi je suis ici tucci
mais quand anges et l'agencé gère fois
cette petite vidéo sur la démo de grève
qui s'annonce est un jeu vraiment bien
une sorte de le jour tu es tranquille la
nuit a en plus on peut retrouver patrick
avec ce numéro de lui-même
ça vaut le coup ça vaut le coup d'y
jouer on peut le dire merci d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo ça vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à aller mais ça me fera
vraiment plaisir en sortir trois choses
une nouvelle vidéo sur tout le monde
pics bien la cuillère
il